on va continuer à parler d'économie avec
la chronique de l'écho de clerck
anguilles bonsoir clair bon ça nous
allons nous intéresser à un nouveau mode
de restauration
et oui dans cette chronique nous allons
parler de l'arrivée des fous trucks dans
les yvelines
alors de quoi s'agit-il et bien de
restaurant mobile mais attention rien à
voir avec les bonnes vieilles baraques à
frites ce sont des camions avec cuisine
intégrée qui se déplacent de lui en
lieux pour servir de bons petits plats
ils nous viennent des états unis on a
gardé le nom originel food pour
nourriture truck pour camions on peut
donc grosso modo le traduire par camion
restaurants ses restaurants tendances
ont déjà fait beaucoup parler d'eux à
paris mais jusqu'à aujourd'hui il était
difficile d'en trouver dans les yvelines
pour autant ça va commencer à changer
parce que si on regarde bien sur le bord
des routes c'est food truck commencent à
fleurir tout à fait nous avons rencontré
justement un tout nouveau food trucks
qui se déplace dans les yvelines le
kitchen le kitchen pardon à son volant
céline fournier nous sommes allés à sa
rencontre sur le marché de versailles
hall sur le temps du midi un reportage
réalisé avec elodie moi non au milieu du
marché de versailles un drôle de camions
a rejoint les stands de légumes ici on
trouve également des produits frais mais
cuisiner le kitchen et le premier food
truck purement yvelinois le concept un
restaurant mobile dans lequel en cuisine
au milieu des casseroles à céline sert
ses premiers clients
cette ce biais was a profité d'un
licenciement pour réaliser son rêve
quitter le secteur de la communication
et vivre de sa passion la cuisine
le concept du foot rock est un moyen
économique de se lancer mais c'est aussi
pour elle toute une aventure
je pense que j'ai envie de voir des gens
différents chaque jour l'idée de
fidéliser des gens un jour par semaine
ou deux jours par semaine avec des
rendez vous réguliers je trouve ça
plutôt sympa l'idée
voilà leur propose à chaque fois quelque
chose de différent alors vas tu as voyez
la phase 1 le food truck est un
phénomène de mode mais qui a aussi un
certain nombre d' avantage c'est qu'on
est nomade et c'est vrai que dassier un
endroit ne fonctionne pas très bien on
peut toujours essayer d'en trouver un
autre même si c'est beaucoup de travail
pour avoir les autorisations nécessaires
une fois par semaine céline est à
versailles
malgré la pluie le public vient
découvrir sa cuisine française et
assemble déjà plaire c'est la première
fois que je traite ce type de concept
donc mais je pense que ça c'est sympa et
bon il faudrait qu'il fasse un peu
meilleure mais tout c'est une
alternative à ce qu'on peut avoir dans
notre quotidien du restaurant
d'entreprise ou pour certains du
sandwich
ici on est loin du snack rien que des
produits frais et du fait maison
au menu du jour risotto ou et chine au
miel et orange 11 euros le menu complet
une petite pointe de coriandre et faire
de la gastronomie dans un camion ce
n'est pas toujours évident ça n'a rien à
voir avec une vraie cuisine mais mais ça
a son charme
en dehors du marché de versailles le
vendredi le kitchen poster casserole sur
un centre d'affaires à evry 2 jours par
semaine et on a entendu la propriétaire
des lieux dans le reportage qui disait
ça a son charme
au-delà de ça quel intérêt alors 2 000
il est alors un restaurant mobile est
d'abord moins coûteux qu'un restaurant
en dur un camion reste un investissement
moins importants pas de loyer ou de
bâtiments à acheter mais tout n'est pas
plus simple il est parfois difficile
pour 7 foot ruck de se faire une place
céline fournier que nous venons de
découvrir dans ce dans ce reportage
devaient être présentes sur notre
plateau aujourd'hui malheureusement elle
a eu un imprévu à régler ce soir
certains comme commerçant s'oppose à sa
venue sur un prochain événement il ya eu
des cas similaires à paris notamment
wall ou lancement des foutraque beaucoup
de commerçants se plaignaient de
concurrence déloyale
autre difficulté aussi il faut
s'organiser on le voit dans le reportage
l'espace et minimes à ces petits le
kitchen une
mécanique entièrement aménagé à
d'ailleurs été conçu par un ergonome
faut pouvoir se déplacer au mieux à
l'intérieur
leila cydia cette société pardon c'est
l'une des seules qui est implanté dans
le département
c'est une des seules alors ils ont
retrouvé quelques autres et également
les fautes rock parisien vous venir
envahir les yvelines si on peut dire
velizy 2 organise le foot rock festival
du 3 au 20 juin
chaque jour des food trucks se
relaieront devant les portes 2 et 3 du
centre que l'on voit à l'image
on y retrouvera notamment le camion qui
fut l'un des précurseurs
mais aussi bien d'autres nous sommes
allés à la rencontre du directeur de ce
centre commercial pour qu'il nous parle
de cet événement on écoute souvent
l'idée du foutraque c'est d'avoir du
burger là on est sûr de la restauration
asiatique
on va avoir bien sûr des crêpes on va
avoir des clean traditionnel mais
créative
on va aussi avoir un camion spécialisé
dans la mozzarella tout cas c'est
inattendu avec des plats qui tourne
autour de cet ingrédient qui aujourd'hui
à connaît un vrai un vrai succès donc on
est vraiment sur une complémentarité de
l'offre sur une période de trois
semaines qui vient
confortés l'ensemble des incontournables
on peut avoir sur la santé il ya aussi
beaucoup de restaurants finalement ici
des restaurants dur les restaurants dure
généralement sont pas très favorable à
l'arrivée de foutraque
ça a été bien accueillie effectivement
on a pris leur avis on est sur une
période qui est courte qui est de trois
semaines et effectivement lu l'ensemble
des restaurateurs ont compris l'intérêt
novateur l'exclusivité et ont accepté
sur une période courte d'art se voir
effectivement les foutraque sur la
partie extérieure alors lors de ce
festival il y aura également présents la
patate au mobile un food truck créée par
un grand industriel spécialisé dans la
pomme de terre surgelées alors pas sûr
de retrouver du fait maison qui pourtant
l'esprit des fous trucks cette tendance
commence donc déjà à être récupéré par
les grands industriels
le message en tout cas retenir de cette
chronique c'est que nous sommes envahis
par les food trucks a dansé la région
des food trucks
on passe aux infos en plus de cette
chronique de l'écho oui premier enfant
plus le ministre du redressement
productif étaient présents à flins sur
le site de renault lundi il était venu
soutenir l'accord de compétitivité signé
il ya deux mois mais aussi montrer son
attachement au développement de la
voiture électrique la zoé y compris des
images on écoute ce pardon arnaud
montebourg avec des images recueillies
par anthony rech et jonathan littman
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que 85% des
français font moins de 65 km par jour
donc ils n'ont pas besoin de moteurs
thermiques
dallaire et stations-service des
victimes du prix du carburant du diesel
du super du du 95 plomb sans plomb et là
c'est le plein deux euros et c'est pour
nous un changement complet que nous
encourageons avec nos bonus de 7000
euros qui rendent la zoé qui sort des
usines de flins made in france 100%
chauffe la batterie pour l'instant
compétitif voilà donc le gouvernement
encourage les nous avons un objectif de
8 mille bornes de recharge à la fin
d'année 2013 l'année dernière elle avait
une 1800 et aujourd'hui on est à 6
milles donc on a des progressions de
300%
donc on fait notre travail les
collectivités locales sont sollicitées
les supermarchés les parkings
souterrains les autoroutes les autres
stations service d'ailleurs une vente de
l'essence dans d'électricité aussi
voilà donc la filière zéro émission est
en train de s'installer en france
lentement mais sûrement autre
information demain vendredi 31 mai on
célèbre la fête des voisins
la poste a voulu participer aussi à
l'événement ils ont ouvert les portes de
leur plateforme industrielle courrier
aux entreprises voisines 150 salariés de
la zac croix de bonniers sont ainsi
venus sur l'heure du déjeuner pour
visiter le site et manger un bout biffés
parmi eux des salariés des laboratoires
boiron ou encore mettre plus même le
maire de bonnart cissé prêté au jeu une
première qui appelait à la convivialité
interentreprises une dernière info en
plus ce soir dans la chronique de l'écho
à satory le forum entreprises défense
qui vient de se tenir tout à fait donc
on l'appelle le fait de le forum
entreprises défense après place donc qui
hier et aujourd'hui le but réunir les
acheteurs du secteur de la défense les
donneurs d'ordre des armées et leur
fournissent fournisseurs qu'ils soient
des entreprises industrielles
commerciales fabricant ou prestataires
de services en tout 3000 visiteurs 150
exposants des pme dans 80% des cas
et parmi ces entreprises bien entendu on
comptait des entreprises yvelinoise
comme renault trucks defense bertin
technologies ou encore dexter ce forum
cette fête ses 22 ans d'existence
juste pour information le secteur de
l'industrie de la défense représente 165
mille emplois directs et indirects dont
72 milles en ile de france
merci clair pour cette chronique de
l'écho on vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine toujours à la même heure sur
cette antenne